uh while we're speaking maybe it's in my
purse actually because I brought it to
the right person
Nadim you don't have to do that anymore
somebody else can get my purse
what was the question
with them again
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's January 5th 2022 we are live
streaming on Rumble and on YouTube Share
subscribe tap that notification Bell if
you have not and as most of you who are
playing along at home know we now every
day that we do a live show right here we
do a live post game show which
ultimately will be for subscribers only
but for this first week or two we're
letting everybody in uh and you can join
us everyone report.locals.com if you
want to check that out and get some
questions to me in comments and that's
where we relax I sit a little more like
this than I talk and all that good stuff
and we roll right into that on locals
right after the live stream right here
there was no show yesterday because I
was enroute back to Miami from
Tallahassee because I was up there for
two days during Governor Ron desantis's
inauguration and the the ball the gala
in the evening it was a black tie a very
very Dapper and of course the
inauguration itself was in the morning
and you know it was it was thousands of
people probably three four thousand
people jam-packed at the Capitol in
Tallahassee and a real celebration of so
many of the things that I talk about
here and as I was listening to the
governor's speech which will play a
portion of in just a moment it really
was a validation of not just the ideas
that I talk about here but you know
literally my life and the life of the
people in this room and many of you
watching who are new Floridians because
as I always say this is the blueprint
and the guy is picking the right fights
he is finding the right enemies he is
doing the right things and when you do
that you get rewarded with Landslide
election results and uh and perhaps
bigger things in the offing so today's
show is really going to be about that
contrast between what is working here
many of the things that you guys know
about working here in Florida how that
can be exported but really to contrast
that with what's going on in DC right
now because as you know
Kevin McCarthy who really was the
presumptive going to be the presumptive
leader of the house he has lost he lost
five right five votes so far six he lost
six votes so far for those of you
counting at home and there's a bit of a
uh a sort of Republican Insurrection if
I could use that word uh where about 20
Republicans in essence are just not
supporting him uh and they don't seem to
want to cut any deals and it's just
chaos I think there's arguments that
sometimes the chaos and the fighting is
good because that's how you get the
stuff out and maybe you're all stronger
after a battle right you play sports
against somebody that's better than you
you can you can level up along the way
right so that's kind of good in some
ways but the General State of
dysfunction in Washington that nothing
ever gets fixed meanwhile we have
certain places this sunshine state is
the leader on it where things are good
and things are being done right so
that's what we're going to be doing
today uh real quick let me talk to you
guys about bully and Max and then we'll
get to it you know as inflation
surpasses highs not seen in 40 years the
value of the dollar is decreasing with
every passing day you're paying more at
the pump the grocery store for cars and
for housing basic eyes your paper money
is worth less friends the timing
couldn't be any better for my new
sponsor bullion Max bullion Max is a
direct to Consumer precious metals
retailer who can help you diversify into
gold and silver it's a hedge against
inflation it's also security for your
family in times of Crisis and here's why
I love bullion max they're owned by
veterans in the precious metal space and
offer some of the lowest prices on the
internet and they make it so easy to buy
directly from their website I wanted to
help get you started so I worked out a
special offer just for you get bullion
Max's silver starter kit and employee
pricing just go to booleanmax.com Dave
the kit includes five of the most
desirable silver products to invest in
including a silver American eagle and a
silver Australian kangaroo this offer is
limited to just one per household so get
yours now go to bullionmax.com Dave
that's bullionmax.com David now back to
me all right so I was up in Tallahassee
for the inauguration of Governor
DeSantis and it really
it felt good like there were happy
people functional people there was a
celebration of we're doing it right we
live in the right State and by the way
it wasn't just you know when there's an
inauguration you know the lieutenant
governor is also being sworn in the
Secretary of State the Attorney General
there's a whole slew of good people
doing good work in this state and it
really starts with one f word
not that effort the other f word freedom
and that's exactly what governor
DeSantis was talking about in his speech
after being sworn in
fellow citizens
from the space coast
to the Suncoast from Saint John's to St
Lucie from the streets of Hialeah to the
speedway in Daytona
from the Okeechobee all the way up to
mikanopi
[Applause]
Freedom lives here in our great Sunshine
State of Florida
Paul as you can see me upper left back
over there I think I was applauding
instead of tweeting at that very moment
um that's the idea Freedom lives here
the entire uh context of the speech
really was that you can live your life
freely in this place without that crazy
government overreach that we have all
become so used to that has been so
normalized especially over these last
couple years but what else did DeSantis
do because it's not enough just to talk
about Freedom right freedom is just sort
of this like amorphous idea what you
have to do is you have to fight the bad
ideas as they are imported into your
state into your community
Etc and that is exactly what governor
DeSantis has done with this woke
nonsense and and the reverse of woke
nonsense what is it how about normalcy
this bizarre but prevalent ideology that
permeates these policy measures
purports to act in the name of justice
for the marginalized but it frowns upon
American institutions it rejects Merit
and achievement and it Advocates
identity essentialism
we reject this woke ideology
we seek normalcy not philosophical
lunacy we will not allow reality facts
and Truth to become optional we will
never surrender to the woke mob Florida
is where woke goes to die
Standing Ovation on that one I should
also tell you guys that you know they
say that Governor DeSantis doesn't like
the gays that you're not allowed to say
gay here in Florida about two blocks
from the capitol guys you know what
street it was
Gay Street I had a cup of coffee on Gay
Street nobody attacked me it was okay uh
here's the sad that's being sworn in
just for a little bonus something
well and Faithfully perform the duties
of Governor the duties of government on
which I'm now about which I am now about
to enter so help me God so help me God
foreign
thing when you do the right thing
whether you're a governor or whether
you're a citizen or you're married to a
governor or something else when you do
the right thing it becomes contagious
and that is exactly what has happened
with the state of Florida we've got some
info here from the daily wire on on
population movement from July of 21 to
July of 22. now I've quoted some of
these numbers over the last couple
months here but from in that one year
period now remember we're starting here
at July of 21. so you have to remember
the year and a half of covid before that
where California lost you know something
like 400 000 in just in that year but
from July of 21 to July of 22 California
lost about 340
000 people Florida gained about 320
000 people you can see New York there
lost about 300 000 people Texas gained
230 and then and then you see the rest
but that massive contrast that you're
seeing there putting aside all the other
states and all the other stuff you're
seeing there that massive massive loss
that you are seeing from New York and
California the states that are the most
talked about States right those are the
states where everything's supposed to
emanate from culture and everything else
and they're you know they're on the
coasts right like that those are
supposed everything else is between them
those are the places people are fleeing
the most and the people that are fleeing
those States they are coming mostly to
Florida but also to Texas Tennessee and
a couple others they're coming they're
bringing the right ideas they're
bringing jobs they're bringing
communities they're having
uh they're spending their money in these
new communities there's all sorts of
business businesses exploding I mean I
really can tell you that as a as a new
Miami and I mean this place is just
absolutely blowing up in the great sense
of things but let's contrast that with
the not great sense of something blowing
up or should I say imploding and that
does bring us of course to California
you may remember this ad this is a
couple months ago we played this but
you'll you'll see what I'm doing here
this was an attack ad by Gavin Newsom
who clearly is angling to somehow either
replace Biden or replace Kamala or
something right he destroyed San
Francisco as the mayor he's destroyed
California as the governor and then he
has to move up and Destroy more like a
cockroach right they just keep going
well back in July he had this attack ad
on DeSantis and Florida and just watch
this even if you've seen it before just
watch this for just a perfect reversal
of Truth in lit literally everything
that he says I urge all of you living in
Florida to join the fight or join us in
California where we still believe in
freedom freedom of speech freedom to
choose freedom from hate and the freedom
to love don't let them take your freedom
yeah uh the sadness is taking away
people's freedom to love have you guys
loved today have you loved today Conor
loved a little bit today Phoenix a
Little Love Today Daphne did you share a
little love little little smidgen of
love it's all so stupid but but okay I
get it he wants to go after DeSantis
because he sees him as the ascendant one
and doing everything right the the idea
that Newsome would even say the word
freedom is actually kind of nauseating
but you know I know it can be gratuitous
going after Newsome because he's so
obviously evil so you're saying you're
sitting there going Dave it's easy to do
that go after evil Gavin Newsom
could you do something could you go into
the archives could you find something
from when he was mayor that is proof
that he has an absolutely horrible track
record of Destruction
I can here's mayor Gavin Newsom San
Francisco mayor Gavin Newsom back in
2008 laying out his 10-year plan to end
homelessness
We Believe fundamentally that food
solves hunger that shelters soft sleep
and that housing solves homelessness and
if we're going to solve the problem of
those that are out on the streets that
we Define as homeless we better solve
the housing problem if we're going to
have an impact and that's why we
established this framework what we call
a 10-year plan to end chronic homeless
in San Francisco
so to be clear that was 2008 it was a
10-year plan uh as you know it has gone
horrifically awry but it's sort of a
perfect version of what progressives do
with everything food solves hunger that
sounds pretty good put that on a bumper
sticker shelter solve sleep okay that's
kind of right at some level I suppose
housing solves homelessness
that all sort of sounds right but what
what do you have to do with progressives
you just have to peel off that little
thin veneer of kind of sound and good
and seeming to be right and then you
realize these are just words that they
put together housing doesn't solve
homelessness homelessness usually is
related to bad economic conditions and
drug use and mental health and all those
things just putting somebody in a hotel
room well now you've housed them did you
solve the problem no he exacerbated all
of these problems so he literally
destroyed San Francisco at one time was
one of the most beautiful functional
cities in America I remember going to
San Francisco for the first time about
10 years ago and it was one of the first
cities that I had ever gone to I mean
this is this is hard to believe that I I
within an hour of being there I was like
I could move here I would be happy here
like there was something actually great
going on there and of course the the
proximity to Silicon Valley and there
was an economic engine that was going
great and there was a sense of true
tolerance in all of these things and it
has completely bottomed out but don't
take my word for it we have videotape
foreign
obviously there's tons of videos of that
the point of all of this is that when
you have bad policies when you just say
the right thing when that's completely
disconnected from reality you will
literally destroy your state and then
there will be other places that are
doing it right and then you will try to
destroy them Gavin Newsom is a bad bad
dude but what else is he up to well he
wants California to become a sanctuary
state for teens that want to transition
so if you're a boy and you're like
Barbie and you want to chop you're nuts
off he wants to hook you up we've got a
info on that from the post post
millennial on Sunday a bill that
designates California as a sanctuary for
teens and children who want medicalized
gender transitions went into effect
Governor California governor Gavin
Newsom signed the legislation
legislation which is titled simply
gender affirming Health Care into law on
September 30th California Senator Scott
wiener wiener wiener can you believe
this his name's weiner the guy's
literally trying to chop kids genitals
off originated the bill in January of
2021 and it passed the California
legislature over the summer weiner has
also brought forward bills that relax
laws for the sex offender registry puts
biological males in women's prison and
has worked to decriminalize those who
infect others with HIV after not telling
them of their positive status weiner
also supports public heroin injection
sites and decriminalizing prostitution
the law allows individual minors or
minors with their family to be
unencumbered from out-of-state
authorities who have warrant subpoenas
or other child custody jurisputans so as
long as the minor is now in California
looking for a prescription of cross-sex
hormones or surgical gender reassignment
do you get all this first off this
wiener guy I mean the jokes write
themselves I don't even feel like they
wouldn't want okay that's that okay but
do you want to understand what they want
to do they want they call it gender
affirming care it's to me if you were
affirming someone's gender they would
walk in and say hello I'm a 15 year old
boy and you would say oh well you're a
15 year old boy that would be affirming
if a 15 year old boy walks into an
office and says I'm a 47 year old woman
and you say well let me see what drugs I
can give you to figure that stuff out
that doesn't seem very affirming to me
also if you use a scalpel to chop their
nuts off not affirming but this is the
orwellian use of language that these
guys do with everything but that's
what's going on in Cali right so while
while as DeSantis said woke comes to die
here in Florida in California they will
bring you your brother your sister they
will ignore other states laws and they
will do everything they can to put a
young child on drugs so that they can
pretend that they're another gender
that's sort of where we're at with all
of that we found this video which is
kind of interesting this is from back in
June uh this is while they were trying
to figure out if this bill would get
passed here is a woman who transitioned
as a teen uh who is now a d transitioner
and there's an awful lot of these people
you're not going to see them on
mainstream media because obviously it
goes completely against the narrative
but just the idea
that you're a 15 year old girl who can
take a certain amount of drugs maybe
visually appear as a boy you suddenly
may find that as a 23 year old man your
problems still exists and now you have a
whole slew of other medical problems and
financial problems and spiritual
problems and and much more in any event
here is a woman who transitioned as a
teen testifying against this bill
because she is now detransitioned
my name is Chloe Cole and I am a 17 year
old the transitioner from the Central
Valley I was medically transitioned from
ages 13 to 16. my parents took me to a
therapist who affirmed my male identity
and the therapist did not care about
causality or encouraged me to learn to
be comfortable in my body
he brushed off my parents concerns about
the efficacy of hormones puberty
blockers and surgeries my parents were
given the threat of suicide as a reason
to move me forward in my transition
my endocrinologist after two or three
appointments put me on puberty blockers
and injectable testosterone at age 15 I
asked to remove my breasts my therapist
continued to refer my transition I
attended a Top surgery class that was
filled with around 12 girls that thought
were they were men most are my age or
younger none of us were going to be men
we were fleeing from the uncomfortable
feeling of becoming women
I was unknowingly physically cutting off
my true self from my body irreversibly
and painfully
there's obviously a lot more to that but
you really must understand this is this
is a girl that is a biological girl who
then once she had some feelings around
puberty and as she said becoming a woman
they decided to well they were going to
take her breasts off and Drug her and
all of these other things now she wants
out of all of that having realized that
that it it was either a phase or
whatever it might be and that is not to
ignore the .000 whatever it is one
percent of people that genuinely are in
the wrong body and then of course you
guys know at least my feelings on this
as an adult you can do whatever you want
but California as a state wants to be
able to take children away from their
parents wants to be able to mutilate
children that's what California wants to
do but this woke policy is not specific
unfortunately to California but it is
now infecting virtually every level of
our federal government and pretty much
all of our national leaders Joe Biden is
exactly the same you may remember before
Joe Biden was president when he was
running when he said if you're a chick
and you're going to jail or you're a
dude and you're going to jail it's not
what's on your birth certificate that
matters to decide whether you're going
to a male or female prison it's what you
identify as and then you know you're not
going to believe this suddenly a big ass
300 pound giant dude is like yeah call
me Mary and then he's raping women in
women's prisons that's really what we're
dealing with right now it's just so
bananas ridiculous anyway here is Rachel
Levine what is Rachel Levine's official
title she is the Deputy Health secretary
so so he I'm gonna say he because as far
as I know Rachel Levine lived his entire
life as a man was married had kids a
couple years ago decided to become
Rachel Levine I don't know what his
genital situation is I don't really care
but what Rachel Levine has become is one
of the key mouthpieces for not only
pushing this gender stuff into schools
and throughout all of our cultural
cultural institutions but also to ensure
that those of us and I would include
myself in this those of us who speak out
against him and against these really
terrible ideas uh that we will be
silenced by big Tech surprise rights
technically he is the U.S assistant
secretary for health here's a video of
Rachel Levine
so health
bills have a critical role to play we
must continue and to expand their work
to address Health misinformation
directly with their patients now this
includes but it goes beyond covet 19. so
I'd like to just talk briefly about
another area of substantial
misinformation that is directly
impacting Health Equity in our nation
and that is the Health Equity of sexual
and gender minorities
there is substantial misinformation
about gender affirming care for
transgender and gender diverse
individuals we are in this nation facing
an onslaught at the anti-lgbtqi plus
actions at the state levels across the
United States and they are dangerous to
the public health and we need to use our
clinician's voice to collectively
advocate for our tech companies to
create a healthier cleaner information
environment
I think you see what we're doing here
you see why this is all so dangerous so
they confuse you with their language of
gender affirming care while it is
completely unaffirming that's one thing
but then if you talk about it what they
want to make sure just like they did
with covid if you if you have questions
about the vaccine if you don't want
mandates if you just don't feel that the
the machine which has lied about so many
things is is should just be bowed to at
all times they want to make sure that
they can censor you through big Tech or
whatever other means and God only knows
what other means that they have just a
little bit more info on Rachel Levine
Rachel Levine who is 65 year old now 10
years ago divorced his name was Richard
Levine so Rachel Levine used to be
Richard Levine dick Levine so we got
weiner over there and Dick I mean really
this is like the Matrix isn't even
trying anymore it's dropping so many
hints you know so dick Levine uh had two
kids and at 55 years old divorced his
wife Martha I don't know that also seems
funny to me only better if it would be
Karen so dick divorces Martha with two
kids at 55 and then puts on a dress and
is now the assistant Health secretary in
charge of making sure that we're going
to chop kids genitals off and silence
them silence the people who oppose it on
Twitter it is just completely ridiculous
but now let's continue the
Ridiculousness because there are real
problems right like the woke stuff and
gender transitioning and all that like
it's an important cultural thing because
it's connected to censorship and Free
Speech right the obsession the the idea
that any of us have to talk about this
trans stuff is is sort of ridiculous
because in a sane Society it's such a
tiny amount of people and whatever you
do again as an adult it just shouldn't
matter we have real issues real issues
would include the fact that our border
is open and we all know it and we had
more border crossings this year than any
other year in American history Joe Biden
refuses to go down to the border and
when a certain orange man a couple years
ago used to talk about a border and try
to build a wall they said he was racist
that's the same guy
that when he said we should stop flights
from China because of kovid they said he
was racist about that but just in the
last couple days the Biden
Administration has now extended I think
until April of 2023 if you're coming
from China you have to have a negative
covet test sounds a little racist to me
but you know what are we going to do
anyway uh here is black lesbian press
secretary Corrine Jean-Pierre telling
Steve Ducey uh no Peter Ducey sorry
Steve's the dad Peter Ducey that Biden
is focused on the border and this is
somehow Republican's fault
does anybody around here think that the
southern border is secure
what I can tell you is this is a
president has been working since day one
uh to work on border security uh to make
an immigration a priority that's why he
put forth a comprehensive immigration uh
reform plan legislation and here's
here's the thing as the president is
coming forward and trying to come up
with Solutions but the difference here
is that you have Republicans as you know
who are doing political stunts
okay so just like meaningless dribble
right like she just nothing from day one
the Republic you know the president's
Been Working On The Border and it's just
like he refuses to go down there we know
they are letting all these people in
they put you know all of these border
towns have massive Jeopardy and nobody
cares but if you send 30 people up to
Martha's Vineyard all hell is going to
break loose and the reason I'm showing
you that clip is because now I want to
transition into we've gone from we
started with with functioning highly
functioning competent decent leadership
here in the flourishing free state of
Florida I contrasted that with the
disaster of California and showing you
that the policies of the guys 15 years
ago 2008 Gavin Newsom talking about
homelessness has now completely ravaged
his State and then we showed you that
people are now leaving his state to come
to the State of Florida right so this is
all happening and it's connected with
all the gender stuff where does this all
come from it comes from places like
California uh and then you take all of
those things and then the issue really
is that we have a federal government we
have a a federal government that is
completely derelict in its Duty right
now whether it's to make sure the
economy is chugging along properly and
not spend too much or making sure the
borders are protected or anything else
but now let's shift really to the to
sort of inside nonsense of Washington
because what is happening right now is
as you know even though that massive Red
Wave never happened the Republicans did
get the house so they get to pick the
leader and the presumptive leader was
Kevin McCarthy let me just say on a
personal note I have interviewed Kevin
McCarthy I've met him a couple of times
we've done a couple events together I
think he's a decent dude I actually do
understand some of the frustrations with
him that he feels like a little bit of a
swamp creature and people want him to be
more hardcore Republican or whatever
that is politics is just messy you have
to cut all sorts of deals is what it is
so I'm actually at this very juncture
I'm not even taking a position on who I
think should get it but the point is
that after six votes they have tried to
now put him in
six times it has failed and now there is
a new crop of Republicans that seem to
be getting some momentum so I want to
contrast what's going on here in Florida
where it's functioning with to the to
the wider Republican field which is not
functioning right now so before we get
to that though uh who's out on this
thing well it's Nancy Pelosi so we
thought we'd show you her last gavel
drop ever the 20th Amendment to the
Constitution the terror declares the
second session of the 117th Congress
adjourned then I die
foreign
all right that's it for Nancy Pelosi I
am told that after that she went
directly to the Crypt and on Sunday
nights at nine o'clock on HBO they will
let her out of the coffin and she will
tell very very scary stories and if you
get the reference I dig yeah uh anywho
uh here is video of CNN which is really
loving the fact that Kevin McCarthy has
now made history uh by losing the
speakership in the first round it's the
first time it's happened in about 100
years reality is that he just made
history not in a good way as being the
first in a 100 years the first man to
lose the speakership in the first round
and you see on the screen that Hakeem
Jeffries has 212 as you noted
okay so you have to understand when
you're seeing that and you see Hakeem
Jeffries having more than him it's
because everyone gets to vote not just
because your parties technically has
more members in the house everyone still
gets to vote so Andy Biggs got these 10
votes uh there were a couple outstanding
votes at that point but the point is
that was the first round of the voting
he's lost five subsequent rounds and it
ain't looking good now interestingly
Donald Trump has been backing Kevin
McCarthy and a lot of the base doesn't
like McCarthy because they feel like
McCarthy turned on Trump or something
like that but Trump seems to still be
backing McCarthy whether they like it or
not here's a a comment from Trump on
Truth social uh do I have to read it
with the crazy caps and all that let's
see here we go some really good
conversations took place last night and
it's now time for all of our great
Republican house members to vote for
Kevin close the deal take the Victory
and watch crazy Nancy Pelosi fly back
home to a very broke in California the
only speaker in U.S history to have lost
the house twice Republican do not turn a
great Triumph into a giant embarrassing
defeat it's time to celebrate you
deserve it Kevin McCarthy will do a good
job and maybe even a great job just
watch you know I have to say that I'm
actually in agreement with Trump's
General position there the general
position of like guys you have a chance
now you may let's just say Kevin
McCarthy's not perfect oh my God a human
being who's not perfect but let's say
he's kind of okay and Republicans are
feeling pretty good because fauci's out
of the way and Pelosi's out of the way
and maybe you can do a couple
investigations look into the laptop
elon's got Twitter like there's momentum
you could use here Trump's point is guys
you have a victory here just run with it
as opposed to trying to bring in all
these new guys now I get why the new
guys are frustrated
they've had it with Republican
leadership what do I always say you
don't have to be Republican but you
can't be a Democrat but the Republicans
are most likely going to fail you too
and I think that's what Republicans are
struggling with right now do we do we
just freaking burn the whole thing down
and start anew or do we take a victory
and see what we can do with it everyone
can have their own opinion on that uh
here's Texas Congressman uh chip Roy uh
laying out why he is one of the
Republicans that is not into the
McCarthy situation fact is this place
has to change
it has to change
and the change comes by either adopting
rules and procedures that will make us
actually do our job or it comes from
leadership
and people ask me what do you want
I want the tools or I want the
leadership to stop the swamp from
running over the average American every
single day
we can't keep doing this
I'm going to sit here until we figure
out how to stop spending money we don't
have
okay so Roy's position basically and I
think a lot of people have this position
is that Kevin McCarthy will just give
you more of the same so we must do
something else right so I think there's
good arguments on both sides I genuinely
do there's the the Trump argument of
guys you've got to win here take the win
see if you can get anything done and
then there's this other position of Chip
Roy Lauren bobert Matt Gates couple
other people which is basically like no
that will just ultimately lead us to
that's just ever so slightly slower
descent to hell right so I I get the
arguments on both sides both sides but
now that McCarthy has lost six votes uh
people are looking in other directions
now that the idea that someone is going
to get you know the 200 whatever it is
votes 250 what do they need to win it's
around 218 something like that the idea
that someone else is going to get it is
extremely messy we shall see what
happens uh the other ironic part of all
of this is that if a couple Republicans
defect and vote for this Hakeem Jeffries
guide then the Democrats are running it
again like the whole thing is so wacky
anyway uh chip Roy who we just showed
you right there he has now nominated
someone else someone else who I think is
a pretty freaking good dude who I had on
the show a couple weeks ago uh
Republican Congressman Byron Donalds he
is the congressman from Southwest
Florida Southwest Florida is Fort Myers
Naples this is the area that was crushed
by Hurricane and just a couple months
ago
uh he now is on the list of people that
are going to be voted on and here's chip
Roy calling for his nomination
yesterday
my first vote for speaker of the house
was for Byron Donalds
today I'm rising to nominate Byron
Donald's for Speaker of the House of
Representatives
[Applause]
well all right now who who is Byron
Donald's going to vote for
Donald's McDonald's
[Applause]
Donald
okay let's do it uh if you don't know uh
much about Byron Donald's he is a Take
No Nonsense guy he's doing a great job
like most of our Representatives here in
Florida uh and outside the capitol
yesterday he was asked like are you
going to pay a price because McCarthy's
going to be pissed at you the way the
machine operates like you're you're an
insurrectionist at the moment by going
against the powers that be and I thought
his response was pretty fantastic
are you worried about retribution after
the fact there was threats that folks
that weren't going to vote for McCarthy
would be kicked off committees now you
put yourself in a pretty public position
opposing who the person that could be
the speaker are you worried about
retribution man I'm six two two seventy
five I'm not worried about that
he's a big dude he is a big dude so he's
not worried about that uh now depending
on what contrast you're using on your
computer or your TV right now you may or
may not have noted that Byron Donald's
happens to be black now I don't really
care about his skin color I don't think
most Americans care about his skin color
I certainly don't think that chip Roy
cares about his skin color and I have no
doubt that every leftist uh in the
country every quote-unquote journalist
thinks that chip Roy's a racist and here
he is nominating a black dude but okay
let's not play identity politics like
them uh Corey bush is a representative
from Missouri she is a progressive she's
sort of a squad type and what do you
have when you have a progressive well
you just have a racist generally you
just have a good old-fashioned racist uh
they just you know they doctor it up a
little bit so it seems like it's not
racism but it is here is Corey Bush's
tweet about Byron Donald for what it's
worth Byron Donald's is not a historic
candidate for speaker he is a prop
despite being in Black he supports a
policy agenda intent on upholding and
perpetuating white supremacy his name
being in the mix is not progress it's
pathetic look Corey bush is a racist she
has no business being in politics that
is that is just racism she thinks that
that guy has to think a certain way
because of his skin color she she's an
idiot she thinks all the wrong things
but I don't think it's related to her
skin color right a white woman could say
that and it would be racist and a black
woman could say it and it would be
racist Byron Donald's is instituting
white supremacy could you get me the
list of are you on the computer there
could you get me the list of white
supremacy policies that Byron Donalds
has instituted in Fort Myers since he
has been Congressman can we get all of
that white Supreme anything anything out
of zero nothing out of Naples they don't
have separate water fountains for people
in Naples nothing
these people are ridiculous absolutely
ridiculous anyway I had Byron on when we
were in DC uh right after the election
and we talked about Optics in DC and yes
being black
let me ask you something else just about
being here in DC and being somewhat new
in Congress and that technically you
don't look exactly like what a generic
Congressman looks like you're you're
black is that that's what my guys told
me right before they said we were trying
to figure it out my mama said it came
out the room so yeah
um how does it feel to be in this you
know like when you're doing your thing
in Florida and it's just kind of working
and then you come to a place like this
where it's all about the jockeying and
the media and everything else like do
you like being here when you're in DC
doing your thing sometimes like just to
be straight with you man this place is
surreal like it's still surreal that I'm
here that I'm doing this yeah I told my
colleagues you know you know after this
conference chair thing they were like
man you know it didn't work out how do
you feel and I'm like are you kidding me
if you look at my life going up from
Brooklyn New York all the struggles I've
been through to being in the room doing
this yeah man I'm playing with house
money man so that part is the static for
me yeah
um now just keeping it real because this
is what I do the petty backstabbing
stuff in DC man I don't like that kind
of stuff yeah like I'm a man if you feel
a certain way say it yeah I will respect
you if you do I don't do all the back
talk backstabbing stuff I don't like
that stuff
ready it's valid huh right like pretty
good isn't that what you want out of a
politician here's what I believe I'm not
afraid of people I'm gonna say it to
your face I'm not going to do all that
petty nonsense so he is now nominated we
shall see what happens my my guess is
that it's probably not going to happen
this time around but this guy has a
freaking bright future regardless and I
actually asked him about that future
what do you want to do after being
Congressman for a couple of terms
we have a governor who might move on to
some other things there's all sorts of
interesting opportunities and also a
Republican party that's obviously in
flux right now and and needs some new
voices
what do you think about that when I left
this when I left the state household my
colleagues said um would you ever come
back and I said I'm only coming back one
way
ah
you catch what he did right there if he
only comes back to the house it's only
going to be one way and that would be
Governor if perhaps our governor was to
find another gig maybe he would do that
which he would be probably pretty great
at anyway the whole purpose of the show
today really was to obviously show you
that contrast between where it's working
where it's not working but all of that
being said you know this an internal
fight within a party the media is going
to love this right because the idea that
Republicans are fighting Republicans and
they could lose control of the house and
somehow you'll get a Democrat I don't
think that's going to happen but like
Republic like the media the machine all
that stuff it will love this fight they
will try to make everyone look
incompetent and like backstabbers and
it's the swamp and these are Congress
people in DC there are plenty of
incompetent backstabbers there but
generally a little chaos uh is good
right like a little chaos says to the
machine hey people are kind of
frustrated you guys got to be a little
bit better that's why even if you watch
our videos from from before Christmas
when they were jamming through this 1.7
trillion dollar deal I was defending
McCarthy because he kept saying hey guys
how about we just don't vote on it now
and then we'll be in charge in just a
couple weeks now that didn't come to
fruition but it's like that was the
chance right like get these guys and
this is Trump's argument too it's like
hey you've got to win here you throw
McCarthy in and let's just see what
happens that's better than losing
control of the whole thing
but let these people fight it out and we
shall see I don't know if you know this
but I live in Florida so I'm going to be
okay either way where do you live uh
guys as you know starting uh as of this
week we now do a post game wrap-up on
locals you can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com I think the link
to the specific post is right down below
I'm going to take some questions and
some comments and uh maybe we'll get
personal who knows we'll see what
happens we're going to give you a cold
close right here and then hang tight
we're gonna play a little bumper and
we'll roll right into the post game show
uh in about 30 seconds I will see the
rest of you tomorrow
I got an invitation to do Tucker
Carlson's show tonight
there's no way
of reasons
[Music]